Ja, also das Bild vervollständigen sie dadurch, dass sie eben noch Daten von dritten Firmen aufkaufen oder dazu kaufen quasi. Sogenannte Data Broker ist eine eigene Branche, inzwischen Millionen, Milliarden Branche. Firmen, die nur darauf spezialisiert sind, aus allen möglichen Quellen Daten über Menschen zu sammeln und auch wieder in individuellen Profilen zusammenzuführen. Das geht irgendwie von dem Bonusprogramm Shopping-Daten über Kreditkartenbetreiber, Gesundheitsdaten.
Sie haben eine Karte dabei?
Zum Beispiel, genau. Die sind auch wiederum im Third-Party-Web-Tracking-Geschäft mit dabei. Also die haben selber eine große sozusagen Arbeit daran, möglichst umfassende Profile zu haben. Und von denen wiederum kauft Facebook noch Informationen dazu, führt das auch wieder zusammen mit dem, was sie schon wissen, über die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer anhand von Identifiern, E-Mail-Adresse, Bekundennummer, Payback-Nummer, irgendwas, damit das Bild noch vollständiger wird. Also damit auch beispielsweise nach dem offlineen Einkaufsverhalten getrackt werden kann.
Also, ich versuch das mal sozusagen an deinem Beispiel zu blöden. Also ich benutze immer für alles eine eigene E-Mail-Adresse. Aber ich habe eine Kundenkarte, wo ich mit einer E-Mail-Adresse angemeldet habe. Und die zeige ich jedes Mal vor, wenn ich in der offlineen Welt etwas einkaufe. Und das ist dieselbe E-Mail-Adresse, mit der ich mich bei Facebook angemeldet habe. Dann sagt Facebook also, lieber Kundenkartenbetreiber, ich kaufe mal bitte die Datensätze von dir.
Da sind wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Schritte zwischen. Da ist eben der Data Broker dazwischen sozusagen.
Es gibt Leute, die nichts anderes machen, außer Daten verkaufen. Und dann werden diese Datensätze und dann guckt Facebook, ah, E-Mail-Adresse passt über ein, super, kann ich jetzt...
Das ist einerseits, um das Profil sozusagen zu vervollständigen. Die andere Funktion, wofür das eingesetzt wird, ist, dass die sozusagen ihren Werbekunden dann wiederum sagen wollen, Erfolgsmeldung geben können, also Erfolgsmessung machen können. Also dann wirklich mit nachverfolgen. Der Typ, der auf deine Anzeige geklickt hat, die wir hier ihm gezeigt haben, der hat am Ende in den Laden gegangen und hat dein Scheißprodukt gekauft.
Der hat es nicht mit deinem Online-Job gekauft, aber der war dann...
Übrigens heute, aber hat Facebook oder gestern Abend hat Facebook bekanntgegeben, dass sie das runterfahren wollen oder einschränken wollen. Diese Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zufrieden.
Okay, wir reden gleich darüber, warum das jetzt gerade so sagen krass für Facebook, also krasser als sonst sozusagen ist, aber es ging noch um Staubkörner auf einer Linse und es ging noch um Filter. Also ging noch um Fotografie in sozialen Netzwerken.
Ja, also da hätten wir einmal so die Instagram-Fotoanalyse. Und zwar haben Forscher herausgefunden, dass man allein anhand der Wahl der Filter mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit voraussagen kann, ob ein Mensch eher depressiv ist oder nicht. Und falls ihr euch fragt, was man über euch so rausfinden kann, ja, wenn ihr einen eher so auf dem Blaufilter steht, wie beispielsweise ich oder den Graufilter oder Schwarz-Weiß und nicht so viele Menschen auf euren Bildern habt, dann würdet ihr wahrscheinlich da ins depressive Raster fallen. Und wenn ihr wenig Likes bekommt. Also so bei den Likes, ja, hätte ich vielleicht noch Glück, aber ich hab tatsächlich hauptsächlich eher traurige Bilder von wie Bürger in echt aussehen und so Sachen. Und ich liebe den Blaufilter.
Aber Menschen mit wenig Likes sind absoluten Zahlen? Oder Menschen, die sozusagen so und so viele Folle haben, die aber nicht deren Fotos liken?
Das weiß ich so im Detail nicht. Was aber auch noch interessant ist, Facebook hat noch so allerhand Patente angemeldet. Und man muss sich ja auch vor Augen führen, die machen unglaublich viele Studien mit ihren Daten und ich alles davon veröffentlich nie. Aber ein Patent, was sie angemeldet haben, geht um das Thema Staubkörner auf Fotolinsen. Also wir kennen das alle. Unser Smartphone ist klinisch rein und sauber, keine Bakterie weit und breit.
Ich putze auf gar keinen Fall gerade meine Kameralinsen.
Ja, also es gibt tatsächlich mittlerweile Analyse-Tools. Sie hat Facebook patentieren lassen, die feststellen können, ob zwei Fotos von derselben Kamera kommen, allein anhand der Analyse von Kratzern und Staubkörnern. Das heißt, wenn das selbe Foto oder ein Foto mit diesem Staubkorn-Indikator von zwei unterschiedlichen Geräten gepostet wurde, selbst wenn die Leute sonst keine Connection haben, kann man sagen, irgendwie müssen die zusammenhängen, weil die posten ein Bild vom selben Gerät.
Letztes Beispiel. Aber das ist wirklich mein Lieblingsbeispiel, für das, was Facebook selber sagt, was ihre Targeting tut, was sie mit den Daten machen können. Die sind dabei erwischt worden im vergangenen Jahr, wie sie in Australien bei einer Großbank Werbung gemacht haben, dafür gesagt haben, hier kommt zu uns, nutzt uns, um sozusagen Targeted Advertising zu machen. Denn wir sind die Besten. Bei uns könnt ihr nämlich, das war das, womit sie es gepitcht haben, emotional verletzliche Teenager identifizieren, ausfindig machen. Die könnt ihr in den Momenten erreichen, wenn sie sich, Zitat, am wertlosesten fühlen. Und dann kommt eure Werbung und ihr könnt ihnen den Boost geben, den sie brauchen sozusagen. Das war das Szenario, mit dem sie dafür geworben haben.
Aber hat dann Facebook gesagt, ja, das war nicht wir, das war nur der ausländische, australische...
Genau, sie haben am Ende gesagt, das war ein tragischer Einzelfall.
Ah, natürlich.
Einen haben wir noch. Und zwar hat das Datenteam von Facebook sich auch, sag ich mal, Systematiken von Beziehungen und Liebesgeschichten angeschaut. Und die haben beispielsweise festgestellt, dass man sehr genau sagen kann, wer mit wem wahrscheinlich verbandelt ist allein anhand der Freundeskreise. Weil man kennt das ja, wenn man länger zusammen ist, dann hat man immer mehr gemeinsame Freunde und gemeinsame Events. Und diese Dynamiken kann man sehr gut abbilden, selbst wenn jemand, sag ich mal, nicht offiziell auf Facebook seinen Beziehungsstatus bekanntgibt. Und am Tag der Trennung nimmt die Zahl der ausgetauschten Nachrichten Interaktionen im Schnitt um 225% zu.
Also dann nicht mit dem Ex-Partner, Partnerin, sondern mit allen anderen?
Nee, mit dem Ex-Partner. Also das ist wahrscheinlich dann so die Sache, du hast noch was von mir, letzte Konflikte, wie konntest du mir das antun? Und das eben, sag ich mal, in so einer ganz charakteristischen Weise.
Aber also umgedreht sagen, ich als Werbetreibender würde also sagen, also liebes Facebook, zeig doch mal den Leuten, die ihrem Partner gerade sehr viel mehr Nachrichten schreiben als sonst, meine Bar an.
Das Schwierige ist ja, wir reden einerseits über Potenziale, dessen was möglich ist, und wir wissen immer nicht genau, was machen sie dann tatsächlich oder was ist tatsächlich möglich. Einige oder viele der Sachen, über die wir gesprochen haben, sind bekannt, dass beispielsweise eben diese inferierten Schlüsse über Fernbeziehungen sozusagen, dass das weiter verraten wird. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob sie es anbieten oder ob es bekannt ist, dass sie es anbieten, dass man sozusagen frisch Getrennte ansprechen kann. Aber mich wundern wird es mir jetzt nicht.
Nee, also das geben sie natürlich nicht bekannt, obwohl theoretisch, also zumindest beim offiziellen Beziehungsstatus, ja, also, müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich glaube, an der Stelle ist noch eine Sache, für mich zu sagen, also das Problem, über das sie die ganze Zeit reden, das ist nicht Facebook weiß die Daten und gibt dann eure, also ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, die jetzt gerade von den Neuartigen Wohnraumkommfangs reden, sitzt nicht eure persönlichen Daten werden da weitergegeben, sondern Facebook ermöglicht es, zu sagen, also ich möchte folgenden Personen jetzt etwas zeigen. Und dann wird ein Profil gemacht, was halt möglicherweise ebenso genau ist. Also jemand, der arm ist, Dreck auf der Kameralinse hat und sich gerade getrennt hat, dem kann man sozusagen Werbung anzeigen.
In den USA gibt es auch so eine Kategorie, die nennt sich ethnische Affinität, wo dann sozusagen Hispanic American, African American und so weiter gezielt angesprochen oder ausdeutiert werden können für die Anzeigen.
Und es gab mal so einen kleinen Skandal, dass eine Zeit lang für zielgerichtete Werbung es möglich war, Leute, die Juden hassen, anzusprechen. Und es wurde dann öffentlich, danach hat Facebook natürlich die Kategorie gelöscht, aber es zeigt ja nur, was möglich ist und was in vielen Bereichen auch gemacht wird, wenn es keinen großen Skandal gibt.
Apropos, im natürlichen Verlauf einer Sendung müsste man jetzt sozusagen über die Stelle sprechen, warum halten denn Datenschützer und Aktivisten es für ein Problem, dass eine einzelne Stelle so viel über jemand weiß? Und es gibt dann eine sehr außerufernde Argumentation, die sagt, dass im Prinzip die Idee von Privatsphäre wichtig ist für die Gesellschaft, wie sie funktioniert. Ich würde das gerne heute nicht machen. Also weil wir haben das schon sehr oft gemacht und würde gerne auf die chaosradio.ccc.de verweisen, die Seite, wo die ganzen Podcasts von Chaosradio sind, wo man sich in einem beliebigen, wahrscheinlich am einfachsten ist, wenn man nach Vorratsdatenspeicherung sucht und sich da die Folgen mal anhört, da wurde das ja ausführlich erläutert. Und das Ding, was an diesem Skandal nämlich das Besondere ist ja, es gibt diese Argumentation, warum Privatsphäre eigentlich eher wichtig ist, schon sehr lange. Es ist sehr lange bekannt, was Facebook alles macht. Und es ist auch schon viele Leute, sowohl Institutionen als auch einzelne Aktivisten haben versucht dagegen vorzugehen. Bis jetzt ist nichts passiert. Jetzt ist es aber, dieses Mal scheint es so ein bisschen anders zu sein. Also Facebook scheint, wie soll man das sagen, unter Druck zu geraten oder sich mindestens bemüßigt sehen zu reagieren. Also ich fand es wirklich sehr beachtlich, dass der Mark Zuckerberg dann ein Interview gegeben hat, CNN gegenüber, was er normalerweise in der Art und Weise nicht macht. Also es gibt von ihm so Home-Stories und nette Geschichten und sowas, aber dass er sich aktiv zu einer, man könnte fast sagen Krise äußert, das passiert wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr selten. Und könnt ihr mir jetzt erklären, was ist dieses Mal anders? Also wie kommt es, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Facebook sich ändert, aber wie kommt es denn, dass überhaupt zum ersten Mal so was bemerkbar ist, dass Facebook öffentlichen Druck zu spüren scheint?
Der Aktienkurs ist gefallen. Deshalb reagiert Zuckerberg.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, der Aktienkurs ist ja aus dem Grund gefallen, und zwar weil die Leute oder auch die Aktionäre langsam realisieren, dass die Regulierung am Horizont erscheint und nicht mehr so abstrakt durch die feuilletons wabert.
Aber was genau hat dazu geführt? Was hat dazu geführt, dass die Diskussion jetzt so geführt wird, so hart, dass man anscheinend denkt, okay, das können wir nicht einfach auslösen, da müssen wir regeln. Also ich kriege das nicht ganz gefasst. Also theoretisch ist mir das klar. Aber ich meine, ich habe mich ja schon oder auch Datenschutz und Aktivisten sozusagen regen sich schon sehr lange auf. Und dann, was ist jetzt der Unterschied?
Das Problem mit Datenschutz ist ja immer, Daten spürt man nicht, Daten fühlt man nicht, man spürt die Verletzung von Privatsphäre nicht. Wenn irgendwo jemand ein großes Profil über mich angelegt hat, so ja, weiß ich nicht davon. Also kann ja sein bei der NSA. Und in dem Fall ist es so, dass aus dieser abstrakten Gefahr, dass Datenschützer, Verbraucherschützer waren, ihr könnt anhand eurer Daten manipuliert werden, plötzlich ein konkreter Fall wird. Und plötzlich auch ein politischer Fall wird. Und das macht es natürlich auch nochmal. Also es ist ja eine Sache, ob mich jemand durchleuchtet, um mir halt die passenden Schuhe anzubieten oder vielleicht die passende Hardware. Und das ist was ganz anderes, wenn wir über eine Demokratie sprechen, wo sage ich mal so viele Daten über die einzelnen Wählerinnen und Wähler bei einem einzigen Unternehmen sind, dass man dann zielgerichtet versuchen kann, die öffentliche Meinung in eine Richtung zu drücken. Und wenn man das eben mit bezahlter Werbung macht, dann bedeutet das auch, derjenige, der die größten Datensammlungen hat, derjenige, der sich am wenigsten drum schert und derjenige, der das meiste Geld hat, in Kombination damit, kann die öffentliche Meinung beeinflussen. Und das ist sehr fundamental in einer Demokratie.
Aber irgendwann ist der Sack auch mal voll sozusagen, habe ich auch schon das Gefühl, dass das eine Rolle spielt. Also es ist ja nicht die erste Geschichte, sondern immer wieder das gleiche Muster. Entschuldigen, so ein bisschen zumindest, so verklausuliert entschuldigen. Eigentlich sind wir nicht schuld, aber trotzdem tut es uns leid, falls irgendwas falsch gelaufen ist. Wir ändern uns, wir arbeiten hart daran, dass wir es ändern. Das ist oft genug passiert. Und jetzt natürlich gerade in den USA, die Nachweise oder wirklich nachgewiesenen russischen Manipulationen im Rahmen des Wahlkampfes haben, glaube ich, zumindest in den USA das Klima nochmal deutlich verändert. Also dass da sozusagen russische Gruppen es möglich war, irgendwie im großen Stil Anzeigen zu kaufen, die mitgemischt haben im Wahlkampf, ohne dass es jemandem aufgefallen ist. Das hat, glaube ich, das Klima in den USA nochmal stark verändert. Aber ansonsten, was Katascha sagte, ich glaube nur, es addiert sich irgendwann auf. Und jetzt steht auch die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung vor der Tür.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ich hier interessant finde, ist, wir sind ja fast schon wieder jetzt mit dieser Sendung am Ende des News Cycles. Die Geschichte ist so ungefähr zwei Wochen an und es ist fast schon so, also wir machen das, weil wir es im Chaosradio immer so machen, dass wir eine Sache sehr ausführlich erklären, damit man also nicht nur jetzt gerade, sondern auch in einem Jahr noch, weil man, was war denn damals eigentlich los, kann man das sozusagen hier nochmal genau nachhören. Aber ich frage mich trotzdem, wie lange wird das halten? Und wir können jetzt mal über die verschiedenen, also Konsequenzen sprechen, die das haben könnte, möchte ich wirklich so sagen, Konjunktur. Wir sprechen gleich noch über etwas, was Datenschutzgrundverordnung heißt. Aber zum ersten ist es heute an mir vorbeigeflogen. Ich habe leider nicht gelesen, was genau die Argumentation ist, aber es gibt anscheinend die Idee, Facebook zu verstaatlichen.
Ja, also ich glaube, nach Snowden und der ganzen Geschichten auch in Deutschland, die wir über unsere Geheimdienste und staatliche Behörden wissen, ist glaube ich recht klar, dass man als Datenschützer, als Verbraucherschützer kein staatliches soziales Netzwerk haben möchte. Weil da, wo ein Trog ist, da kommen die Schweine, sagt man ja so schön. Und ja, in dem Fall, wo Daten sind, da entstehen Stellenbegehrlichkeiten. Kann ich noch von abraten.
Okay, ich möchte dann jetzt sagen, dass jetzt spalten. Das eine ist, es gibt große zentral geführte soziale Plattformen. Wie können die möglicherweise betrieben werden, so dass man sagt, okay. Und das andere ist, gibt es Alternative? Wie könnt ihr aussehen? Ich würde zu sagen, wirklich gerne erst bei diesem einen Denken. Ich muss zwar letztens halt immer wieder daran denken, dass es ja ganz früher mal ein soziales Netzwerk gab, das hieß MySpace. Und da kann ich heutzutage kaum einer erinnern. Und das war aber auch, es gab eine Zeit, da war das also groß. Das war nie so groß wie Facebook, aber es war halt groß und gefühlt tatsächlich überall und gekommen, um zu bleiben. Und das war wirklich so in einem Halbjahreszeitraum, würde ich sagen, wo es auf einmal so krass war. Moment, was wir es denn eigentlich aus? Hm, sehr seltsam. So, Facebook. Also mal ausgehend davon, dass das möglicherweise nicht verschwindet jetzt so. Was sind denn für Ideen? Also wird jetzt so, es gibt das Schlagwort der Regulierung. Was, wie will man das denn regulieren? Ich hab neulich mit Tilo Weichert gesprochen, ehemaliger Datenschützer in Schleswig-Holstein. Der hat ja Facebook auch mal verklagt. Da ist ja nie so richtig viel passiert. Also gab es immer so ein kleines News-Ding, und dann war es aber wieder... Was gibt es denn da jetzt für andere Ideen, wie man mit Facebook umgehen kann?
Na ja, also ich glaube, wir müssen in unserer Gesellschaft einfach auch eine Debatte darüber führen, wie weit die Durchleuchtungen für ökonomische oder andere Interessen des menschlichen Lebens gehen darf und wo vielleicht auch eine rote Linie ist. Also um mal ganz niedrigschwellige Regulierungen anzusprechen, wir müssen einfach darüber sprechen, was für Daten überhaupt erhoben werden dürfen, was für Daten überhaupt verwertet werden dürfen. Und vor allem, ob es nicht auch so etwas wie Löschfristen geben sollte für bestimmte Daten. Also als ich mein Datenprofil bei Facebook abgerufen habe, da ist mir auch klar geworden, warum keine Löschfristen in den Facebook-AGB genannt sind. Man löscht einfach Daten nicht, mit denen man Gewinn generieren kann.
Es gibt ein grundsätzliches Problem. Also es gibt ja anscheinend einen großen Bedarf daran, an einem sozialen Netzwerk teilzunehmen. Also diese Milliarden User, die Facebook da hat, sind ja nicht dadurch zu erklären, dass irgendjemand die dahin geprügelt hat, sondern es gibt ja anscheinend so eine Lust daran, da zu sein. Und da gibt es ja zwei Wege, wie so eine Plattform, die betrieben wird, Geld verdienen kann. Das eine ist halt monatlich ein Zehner oder beliebiger Beitrag sozusagen, der immer Leuten so teuer sein wird. Der andere ist, wir machen das genau über dieses Modell. Also wir spielen Werbung aus. Wenn man Werbung ausspielen muss, muss man wissen, wie macht man die hin? Also ist, stellt du jetzt auch das grundsätzliche Modell in Frage?
Ja, also wie der Zufall das will, habe ich meine Abschlussarbeit über die Markteintrittschancen von dezentralen sozialen Netzwerken an der Uni Hamburg geschrieben und tatsächlich denke ich, es gibt noch mehr Modelle. Also wir sollten halt fleißig machen.
Nein, nein, Moment, aber darüber wollen wir später sprechen. Die Frage ist ja, eine zentrale Plattform, die ein soziales Netzwerk ist, die kann ja anders nicht betrieben werden, oder?
Ich glaube aber, es ist ein Mythos, dass Werbung heutzutage nur aufgrund dieser krassen umfassenden Datensammlung passieren kann. Also es gäbe ja auch Modelle, wo man sagen könnte, also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das die Lösung ist, aber ich glaube schon, dass es Werbemodelle gäbe, die nicht ganz so invasiv sind, die beispielsweise, weiß ich nicht, also alleine der Ort, ich will jetzt nur mal ein bisschen Gedanken spielen. Also vielleicht Google wirbt viel oder nutzt viel beispielsweise die Geolokationen in der Suche Anzeigen zu spezialisieren.
Fragt mich alle 5 Minuten, darf ich deinen Ort verwenden?
Ja, aber ich meine, vielleicht könnte man auch einfach mal sagen, ok, bestimmte Informationen nicht oder sozusagen Facebook reißt sich einfach ein bisschen zusammen und versucht nicht dieses creepy alles wissende Ding zusammen zu sein, sondern sagt einfach ok, hey Leute, das ist das Modell, wir finanzieren uns Überwerbung und wir geben euch aber die Möglichkeit, einfach ein bisschen selber mit zu bestimmen, wir informieren euch darüber, was passiert. Problem ist nur, das Geschäftsmodell basiert eben derzeit darauf, dass die Nutzer im Unklaren bleiben und im Dunkeln tappen. Also Facebook arbeitet am Eck massiv daran, dass Nutzerinnen und Nutzer nicht Bescheid wissen darüber, was passiert eigentlich mit den Daten. Also ich würde sagen, Werbung kann man drüber sprechen, fände ich nicht geil. Ich fände andere Modelle gut. Ich würde auch tatsächlich über öffentlich-rechtliche Finanzierung sprechen. Es gibt ja auch noch staatlich-gemeinschaftlich finanzierte Modelle, die nicht heißen, der Staat betreibt es, sondern die noch dazwischen sind.
Ja, wobei ich da immer sagen würde, natürlich kann man das machen, aber dann stelle ich mir mal vor, in Deutschland passiert ein Attentat, da werden die Begehrlichkeiten groß sein, die gesetzlichen Regelungen von Zugriffsbefugnissen ganz schnell wieder aufzuweichen. Wir hatten uns ja vorhin schon drüber unterhalten, eigentlich wäre ja geil, wenn das von einer unabhängigen, gemeinnützigen Stelle betrieben wird, eine Stiftung beispielsweise, wo ich sagen kann, diese Woche wieder geiler Service, überweise ich mal einen Zehner und gut ist.
Das Argument, das an der Stelle immer dagegen kommt, ist ja, Facebook ist ja nur so toll, nur so berühmt geworden oder nur so viel genutzt geworden, weil sie so innovativ sind, weil sie sozusagen, das könnte staatlicherseits oder sozusagen durch eine nicht kapitalgetriebene Finanzierung oder ein nicht kapitalgetriebenes Modell gar nicht, wäre niemand in der Lage, so innovativ zu sein. Das ist ein Gegenargument, das an der Stelle immer kommt. Ich sehe das nicht so. Ich glaube, man könnte, ich finde Facebook auch ohnehin nicht mehr besonders innovativ, aber...
Also davon abgesehen, das Elternnetzwerk, wie es ja manchmal auch genannt wird. Aber noch mal gefragt, es gibt diese Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Also ein Gesetz, ein EU-Gesetz, das demnächst kommt und in dieser Diskussion, wenn man es ein bisschen verfolgert, war das immer so, ja, das kann ja wirklich was helfen. Und jetzt ist es ja, wie ich gerade schon versucht habe, sozusagen zu erinnern, ist es mit Datenschutzgesetzen nicht so, dass die bis jetzt besonders wirksam waren? Was ist denn bei der DSGVO anders?
Also es gibt tatsächlich ja die Fälle. In Spanien ist neulich eine hohe, vermeintlich hohe Strafe gegen Facebook verhangen worden. Genau aufgrund intransparenter Datensammlung. Nutzerinnen und Nutzer wussten nicht Bescheid. Oder das war der Vorwurf eben über das, was mit ihren Daten passiert, wie die für Werbung verwendet werden. Und die haben eine Strafe von einer Million Euro verhangen. Die französische Datenschutzbehörde hat neulich die Höchststrafe von 150.000 Euro verhangen. Das ist natürlich so die große Hoffnung, die jetzt mit der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung mitschwingt, dass Datenschutzbehörden endlich Sanktionsmöglichkeiten bekommen, die sozusagen der gesellschaftlichen Bedeutung des Datenschutzes auch gerecht werden, bis zu 4% des weltweiten Umsatzes.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Also 4% des Umsatzes des Konzerns. Also nicht irgendwie die Facebook-Filiale, die hier in Irland gegründet wurde, oder das Büro, das in Hamburg sitzt, sondern weltweit 4%.
Das ist so die Hoffnung.
Das so ungefähr geht in Richtung einer Milliarde, würde ich sagen.
Aber haltet ihr das für realistisch? Also, dass das auch um und durchgesetzt wird?
Das hängt echt stark von den Datenschutzbehörden ab. Also bislang auch im Rahmen dieser Android-Telefondaten, die gerade sozusagen, das was jetzt gerade noch letzte Woche rausgekommen ist, Facebook greift oder hat lange Zeit auch die Telefonhistorie von Android-Telefonen mit abgegriffen, weil Google da sloppy war, was die Erlaubnisse, App-Erlaubnisse anging. Da sind jetzt auch wieder nur so, ja, ist fraglich, ob das vereinbar ist, so die Äußerung von Datenschutzbehörden geht nicht, steht im Widerspruch zu und nicht, knallharte Aussage, das ist illegal und das werden wir ahnden, wenn wir die Möglichkeiten dazu endlich haben. Ich kann nur hoffen, dass die Datenschutzbehörden das dann tun. Dafür wiederum muss man auch dazu sagen, müssen die entsprechend ausgestattet sein. Die schreien alle auf, dass sie nicht genug Mittel und sowieso auch nicht die technischen Möglichkeiten haben, dann tatsächlich ihrer Aufgabe gerecht zu werden. Das ist noch so ein anderes Thema.
Also, hm, aber ist das denn, hm, also ich würde ja vermuten, es wird sich tatsächlich, also das ist ja eine EU-Gesetz. Da wird sich schon in irgendeinem Land mal eine Datenschutzbehörde finden, die sagt, so Leute, das war's. Schön mal hier die vier Prozent über den Tisch gelegt. Und dann ist ja die Frage, wie jeder darauf reagiert wird. Es gibt ja in der DSGVO auch dieses Marktortprinzip. Also das jetzt sozusagen wirklich, wenn sich Facebook an Nutzerinnen und Nutzer in Deutschland richtet, dann ist es auch hier sozusagen relevant.
Ja, das ist immens wichtig, weil momentan haben ja ganz viele große Konzerne, die sich durch ein Geschäftsmodell basierend auf Datensammeln gegründet haben. Die haben ihre EU-Filiale in Irland. Und Irland ist so eine Art Datenoase im Vergleich zu Steueroasen. Vielleicht Datenoase, wo es nicht nur besonders laxe Datenschutzgesetze gibt, sondern eine sehr laxe Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Problem. Also diese vereinzelte Gesetzgebung bisher, wenn man gegen einen Konzern vor Gericht ziehen will. Also mein ganz konkretes Beispiel Max Schremms hatte wirklich einen epischen Rechtsfeld gegen Facebook geführt. Das ist der junge Mann, von dem ich eben schon erzählt habe, der seine 1222 PDF-Seiten von Facebook rausgezogen hat. Und der wollte Facebook verklagen und musste dann vor Irland, vor Gericht gehen und hat dann nach einem Anwalt gesucht. Und kein auf Datenschutz spezialisierter Anwalt wollte ihn vertreten, weil die natürlich alle, sage ich mal größere Kunden aus diesem Bereich der Datensammlung haben und dann natürlich trotz vielen Spendengeldern keine Lust hatten, ihn zu vertreten. Und am Ende hatte er einen Anwalt, der eigentlich auf Asylrecht spezialisiert war. Und sie haben ihm dann nachher auf Zetteln vorgeschrieben, was er da sagen soll.
Aber teilt ihr trotzdem diesen moderaten Optimismus, was die Datenschutz-Konfortung angeht? Oder sagt ihr, egal, weil in drei Wochen ist sowieso alles wieder wie es vorher war?
Ja, also ich glaube, diese 4% sind schon eine Ansage. Ich glaube, das ist auch die einzige Sprache, die Unternehmen vor allem, sage ich mal, Shareholder-Value maximierend orientierte Unternehmen letztendlich verstehen und auch Datenschutzbeauftragte aus Unternehmen, von denen hört man immer wieder, endlich kann ich mal meine Sachen durchargumentieren und werde auch gehört und werde auch ernst genommen. Nicht nach dem Motto, da müssen wir so ein bisschen, da können wir eventuell mit werben, sondern wenn ihr das nicht macht, dann kann das bis an die Existenzgrundlage des Unternehmens gehen. Natürlich, wie das am Ende ausgelegt wird, das werden wir sehen, aber da kann man ja im schlimmsten Fall hoffen, dass es trotzdem besser wird als bisher. Und das wird es allemal.
Also ich glaube, wir können uns jetzt schon darauf einstellen, dass dann die Gerichtsverfahren losgehen erst mal und dass es dann noch ein paar Jahre dauern wird, bis dann tatsächlich Klarheit herrscht.
Na gut, dann gucken wir mal, was dann passiert und reden jetzt in der nächsten halben Stunde gleich nochmal über die anderen möglichen Alternativen. Vorher gibt es noch einmal NerdNews geschrieben von Mo, vorgetragen von Helena und danach Musik von KingShi, Blue Elephant heißt sie, danach Nachricht mit einem Verkehr.
Die Transportverschlüsselung TLS 1.3, die Datenpakete im Internet verschlüsselt, ist als Standard der Internet Engineering Taskforce IETF verabschiedet worden. Sie bringt modernere Verschlüsselungen. Außerdem wird schon der Verbindungsaufbau kryptographisch gesichert. Behörden, Banken und Betreiber von Rechenzentren forderten bis zuletzt Nachschlüssel, konnten sich aber nicht durchsetzen. Daher kündigten sie an, sich beim European Telecom Standards Institute für einen Gegenstandard einzusetzen, der ihren Wünschen entspricht. Forscher haben in der Bitcoin-Blockchain an mehreren Stellen illegale Inhalte entdeckt, die von Nutzern eingeschleust wurden. Aufgrund des Funktionsprinzips der Blockchain werden die mehr als 1600 Inhalte weltweit verteilt und können nicht mehr gelöscht werden. Unter den Inhalten seien zwei Linklisten, die auf Seiten mit dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch verweisen. Außerdem ein Bild, das Kindesmissbrauch zeige und damit in den meisten Staaten illegal sei. Damit dürfte es in diesen Ländern also illegal sein, die Bitcoin-Blockchain abzuspeichern. Das könnte die gesamte Kryptowährung gefährden, denn zum Schürfen ist es notwendig, die Datenbank herunterzuladen. Auch andere Kryptowährungen setzen auf die Blockchain-Technik und sind ebenfalls angreifbar. Der Chatdienst Telegram ist vom obersten Gericht der Russischen Föderation verurteilt worden, mit dem Inlandsgeheimdienst FSB zusammenzuarbeiten. Der FSB verlangt von den Telegram-Betreibern Hilfe bei der Entschlüsselung von Chats. Telegram wurde vom Gericht eine Frist gesetzt, der Aufforderung des Geheimdienstes Folge zu leisten, sonst drohe die Sperrung, meldete die Deutsche Welle. Telegram-CEO Pavel Durov erklärte auf Twitter, die Sperrdrohung werde keine Früchte tragen.
Sein Dienst werde für Freiheit und Privatsphäre stehen.
Darf ich? Feind!
Beste Musik mit uns.
Anti-Loken-Gang.
Diesen Sonntag wieder. Auf Fritz.
Es ist kurz nach halb 12.
Mit Benedikt Wenck. Bundesfamilienministerin Giffey will Angestellte in der Pflege und der Erziehung besser bezahlen. Das sagte sie heute bei Besuchen in einem Seniorenstift in Brandenburg und einer Kita in Berlin.
Bei Pflegerinnen und Pflegern denkt sie auch über eine kostenlose Ausbildung und eine bessere Familienfreundlichkeit des Jobs nach. Einen höheren Lohn will Giffey auch bei Erzieherinnen und Erziehern. Wegen des religiösen Mobbings an manchen Schulen fordern einige Zuwandererverbände einen Neuanfang in der Islampolitik. Der Präsident der Bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft der Immigrantenverbände in Deutschland hat sich etwa dazu geäußert, er fordert, dass Parteien, Kirchen und Stiftungen die Zusammenarbeit mit Vertretern des politischen Islams einstellen. Außerdem hat er davor gewarnt, dass es immer mehr Kinder aus muslimischen Elternhäusern gäbe, die andere Schüler angriffen und beschimpften, weil diese nicht an Allah glaubten. Beim US-Sportausrüster Under Armour gab es einen Hackerangriff, und zwar auf die App MyFitnessPal. Etwa 150 Millionen Konten seien betroffen. An der Armour geht davon aus, dass Nutzernamen, Mailadressen und Passwörter geklaut wurden. Kreditkartendaten oder Sozialversicherungsnummern sollen nicht betroffen sein. Die Eisbären haben ihr erstes Play-off-Halbfinalspiel in der Deutschen Eishockeyliga gewonnen. Gegen Nürnberg stand es am Ende 5 zu 1. Alba Berlin hatte in einem Nachholspiel der Basketball-Bundesliga mit 98 zu 68 in Erfurt gewonnen. Alba bleibt damit weiter tabellens weiter. Und in der Handball-Bundesliga haben die Füchse Berlin in Stuttgart unentschieden gespielt mit 24 zu 24. In Berlin Spandau 4 und Marzahn 5 Grad, Ludwigsfelde 3, Falkensee und Königsrösterhausen 4, Lindenberg 5 Grad. Nachts bleibt es erstmal überwiegend trocken mit lockeren Wolken, bis am Morgen dann stellenweise Nebel aufkommt.
Die Temperaturen sinken auf minus 3 bis 0 Grad.
Am Karfreitag dann generell eher schön. Die Sonne scheint auch mal länger, dazu milde Temperaturen von 8 bis 13 Grad. Der Rest der Feiertage dann eher wechselhaft und kühler, bis am Ostermontag wieder die Sonne rauskommt. Auf der B 97 Dresden, Heuerswerda. Zwischen Bernsdorf und Heuerswerda Neidahr in beiden Richtungen, da gibt es einen Wildunfall und außerdem befinden sich noch Wildschweine auf der Fahrbahn. Und noch ein genereller Witterungshinweis.
In Berlin und Brandenburg muss in der Nacht mit Glätte auf Straßen und Wegen gerechnet werden.
Bitte fahrt vorsichtig, und wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz im Live- oder Musikstream hören wollt, dann geht doch mal auf fritz.de slash Streambox.
Heute das Chaosradio im Blue Moon live aus dem Fräulein Fritz in der Frankensteinstraße 47. Ihr könntet noch vorbeikommen, wenn ihr gerade in der Nähe im schlesischen Tor seid und mal live sehen wollt, wie wir darüber reden, ob man ein gewisses soziales Netzwerk mit einem blauen Logo abschaffen können sollte. Dann könnt ihr das machen oder 0331 70 97 110 anrufen, falls ihr noch Fragen habt. Das hat zum Beispiel nämlich Christine geschrieben auf der Studio Message, die ihr auch machen könnt, dass sie das Facebook-Thema und den damit verbundenen Skandal noch gar nicht so wirklich verstanden hat. Und jetzt hier in der Sendung erst mitbekommen hat, was da alles dahinter steckt. Falls also noch Fragen offen sind, könnt ihr gerne die noch stellen unter 0331 70 97 110. Und auch hier die Dinge beobachten, die in der Sendung so vor sich gehen, zum Beispiel verschwinden dann auf seltsame Art und Weise Studio-Gäste. Zu Gast sind heute hier Katharina Nocun und Ingo Dachwitz von Netzpolitik Org, die jetzt gerade während der Nachrichten uns abhandengekommen sind. Wir spielen also jetzt eine kleine Musik und dann sind wir gleich wieder da hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Ja, live ist das Chaosradio aus dem Fräulein Fritz und jetzt wieder auch hier zu Gast, die sie gerade ferdinisierten Ingo und Katascha. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück.
Ich kann auch nur empfehlen, hier mal persönlich vorbeizukommen, sonst nehme ich direkt die Bar.
Ja, da kann man schon mal auch versacken. So, wir haben aber noch viel zu tun der letzten halben Stunde. Wir wollten tatsächlich noch mal drüber reden, was man, wenn man jetzt denkt, so soziale Netzwerke, die großen zentralen Plattformen vielleicht nicht so doll. Was könnte man denn da noch machen? Könnte man da noch mal was machen? Also ich meine, Katarzya hat ja vorhin was von dezentralen Netzwerken erzählt, die unter Umständen eine Lösung sein könnten.
Ja, also es gibt ja unterschiedliche Formen, wie man Netzwerke denken kann. Einerseits gibt es dann so einen zentralen Anbieter, bei dem alles läuft, so wie Facebook. Und dann kann man sich aber auch natürlich vorstellen, ein dezentrales Netzwerk zu machen oder eine Mischform dazwischen, dass es so zumindest verschiedene Knotenpunkte gibt, die den Dienst anbieten. Das hat natürlich auch den Vorteil wie beim Internet, sag ich mal. Wenn ein Knoten ausfällt, dann kommt man immer noch irgendwo ans Ziel. Und dezentrale soziale Netzwerke wurden bekannt, oder, sag ich mal, einem größeren Publikum bekannt, als, ich glaube, im Jahr 2010 war das, diaspora an den Start geht. Und das war so eine Idee von ein paar Studenten, die gesagt haben, wir finden es nicht in Ordnung, was Facebook macht, damals schon. Und die haben gesagt, wir wollen ein datenschutzfreundliches Netzwerk, aber wir sehen auch die Probleme in dieser zentralisierten Struktur. Das heißt, wir wollen ein dezentrales, soziales Netzwerk. Das heißt, es ist freie Software. Und jemand, der sagt, ich möchte jetzt selber, sag ich mal, so einen einzelnen Datenknotenpunkt von diesem Netzwerk aufmachen, der kann sich einfach die Software installieren und quasi mit an diesem sozialen Netzwerk teilnehmen. Das heißt, ich kann auch unter Umständen entscheiden, ich möchte selber so ein Datenknotenpunkt werden. Und kann dann viel selbstbestimmter darüber entscheiden, was, wo, wie gespeichert, verwertet wird.
Naja, aber da muss man ja sagen, mit den digitalen sozialen Netzwerken, also gerade Diaspora ist ein schönes Beispiel, also nicht schön, aber sozusagen ein gutes Beispiel, ist es ja wie mit dem Datenschutz. Das ist eine total nette Idee, aber das ist ja bis jetzt, also grandioser scheitern kann man ja fast gar nicht.
Ja, und deshalb habe ich auch meine Abschlussarbeit drüber geschrieben, weil ich mich natürlich gefragt habe, hey, das ist so eine geile Idee, warum machen da nicht mehr Leute mit? Und ein Grundproblem, was wir bei Kommunikationsnetzwerken aller Art haben, ist der Netzwerkeffekt. Der Netzwerkeffekt besagt, dass ich nicht, also vereinfacht gesagt, ich gehe nicht zu dem Netzwerk, was die geilsten AGB hat, oder die geilsten Datenschutzbestimmungen, sondern ich gehe einfach zu dem Netzwerk, wo die meisten Leute sind. Und es gibt nicht nur einen globalen Netzwerkeffekt, weil mich interessiert ja herzlich wenig, welches Netzwerk die meisten Kontakte insgesamt hat, beispielsweise in China, sondern mich interessiert, was das meist benutzte Netzwerk in meinem Freundeskreis ist. Das heißt, wenn die meisten Leute in meinem Freundeskreis WhatsApp nutzen, oder wenn die meisten Leute in meinem Freundeskreis Facebook nutzen und ich keine Möglichkeit habe, mit einem anderen Dienst mit diesen Accounts zu kommunizieren, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß, dass ich auch diesen Netzwerken beintreten will. Das wäre vergleichbar mit einer Situation, als wenn man beispielsweise von einer GMX-E-Mail-Adresse immer nur E-Mails an alle anderen GMX-E-Mail-Adressen schreiben könnte und nicht beispielsweise zu Posteo oder Mailbox oder als Vornamenachnahme. Genau. Und das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem, was wir eben bei sozialen Netzwerken haben. Wir haben keine standardisierte Sprache, kein standardisiertes Protokollschnittstell, die eben sicherstellt, dass ich mit einem Diaspora-Account nach wie vor mit meinen Leuten auf Facebook in Kontakt bleiben kann.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, das sind ja die Ideen, die aber, also wie sollen die umgesetzt werden? Also ich sehe eigentlich, wenn ich drüber nachdenke, zwei, also gerade zwei große Modelle. Das eine ist ja so eine große Dezentralität, also es wird schon irgendwie von Firmen oder Institutionen betrieben, aber es gibt mehr als nur einen Server-Park, oder andersrum nochmal von vorne. Also Facebook ist ja, wenn man so will, ein großer Computer, ist ja technisch nicht, aber sozusagen ist ein zentraler Anbieter, wo das alles passiert. Und die eine Idee, die du hattest, war ja sozusagen, es gibt das immer noch, dass das sozusagen zentral relativ organisiert wird, aber dann schon so ein bisschen verteilt.
Ja, also distributed quasi. Also was du zumindest sagen kannst, ich hab zumindest die Wahl zwischen A und B.
Ja, und das andere ist, also mal extrem ausprobiert, jeder kann selber sozusagen so ein kleines Netzwerk bei sich betreiben, man kann aber mit ganzen vielen anderen kleinen Netzwerken da sind. Also beim zweiten Fall, da ist ja das Problem, wer soll das denn machen? Ich glaube, zum Beispiel Mail Server ist ja so was. Theoretisch kann ja jeder seinen eigenen Mail Server betreiben. Das ist nur, wenn man nicht Bock hat, mit dem Thema sich zu beschäftigen, ist das ja unfassbar kompliziert. Also einen Rechner so aufzusetzen, dass da ein Mail Server draufläuft, ist Hexenwerk. Also für mich auch. Und dann ist ja die Frage, gibt es Ideen, wie man dahin kommt, dass wirklich jeder so eine kleine Box in seinen Schreibtisch stellen kann und sagt so hier, das ist mein Knotenpunkt, wo meine Daten drauf sind?
Ja, es gibt unterschiedliche Modelle. Es gibt mittlerweile auch einzelne Projekte, die beispielsweise so eine Freedom Box anbieten. Das ist so eine Box, wo ganz viele Dienste vorinstalliert sind, wo ich quasi Plug and Play machen kann. Ich brauche kein großes technisches Wissen, um das selbst bei mir einzustöpseln. Ich glaube aber tatsächlich, dass trotzdem immer noch die Hürde für die meisten Menschen ziemlich hoch ist. Und ich fände es persönlich schon eine Verbesserung, wenn ich zumindest die Möglichkeit hätte, zwischen Anbieter A und Anbieter B zu entscheiden. Sprich, ich habe ja bei der E-Mail Adresse auch die Wahl, ob ich zu Google Mail gehe oder vielleicht zu einem datenschutzfreundlichen Anbieter. Und zumindest diese Wahl zu haben, wäre schon eine Verbesserung.
Ich glaube, die Grundvoraussetzung muss erst mal eben geschaffen werden, dass auch sozusagen unterschiedliche, vielleicht sogar unterschiedliche Netzwerkanbieter oder Plattformanbieter miteinander kommunizieren können. Also Plattform-Interoperabilität ist sozusagen das politische Begriff dahinter. Also sozusagen Standards dafür entwickeln, dass ich von einer Plattform mit Leuten auf einer anderen Plattform kommunizieren kann, damit ich eben nicht, nur weil ich jetzt zu einer datenschutzfreundlicheren Alternative wechsle, sofort mein halbes Sozialleben verliere, weil das noch auf der anderen Plattform hängt. Diese Grundvoraussetzung muss überhaupt erst mal geschaffen werden, dass es einen technischen Standard dafür gibt.
Aber diese Datenschutzgrundfordern, über die wir schon gesprochen haben, die fordert ja unter anderem auch, dass man in Zukunft seine Daten jederzeit runterladen kann in einem maschinenläsbaren Format. Also da wäre ja zumindest sozusagen der Umzug gewährleistet. Ich könnte dann sagen, ich mache bei Netzwerk A, ladet man meine Daten runter, gehe zu Netzwerk B, kann die da wieder hochladen, weil die bestimmt auch Interesse daran haben, dass man die einliest und sowas. Ich glaube, dass über diesen Weg...
Das ist eine Voraussetzung, das hilft einem nur nichts, wenn man dann trotzdem allein ist auf dem neuen Netzwerk quasi. Dann habe ich dann meine Daten mitgenommen quasi und hänge dann trotzdem alleine auf dem anderen Netzwerk. Also, ich meine, technisch ist es ja irgendwie gelungen, dass ich von unterschiedlichen E-Mail-Anbietern mit unterschiedlichen E-Mail-Anbietern untereinander miteinander kommunizieren können. Oder eben auch unterschiedliche Telefonnetze sozusagen zusammengeschaltet werden. Dass ich nicht als Telekom-Kunde nur mit Telekom-Kunden telefonieren kann. Und meine Hoffnung wäre, dass wenn es Standards dafür gäbe, dass Plattformen miteinander kommunizieren können, dass das dann es befeuern würde überhaupt erst mal, dass weitere Alternativen entwickelt werden.
Aber ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn man das jetzt so betrachtet, das klingt irgendwie total einleuchtend, wenn man denkt, ja, das Netzwerk ist so groß, dann müsste ich besser verteilen. Aber die, so viele Sachen, die neu sind, die lassen sich ja dann in diesem Bereich gar nicht so einordnen. Also zum Beispiel kann ich mir, also ich kann mir theoretisch vorstellen, okay, es gibt so was anderes, das ist so ähnlich wie Facebook und da kann man dann irgendwie miteinander reden. Aber zum Beispiel zwischen Snapchat und Facebook eine Dateninteroperabilität wäre ja Quatsch sozusagen, weil es sind ja völlig verschiedene Ansätze von was ich mit meinem neuartigen Grundfunkumfangsgerät mache.
Ja, also man müsste sich schon zusammensetzen mit unterschiedlichen Anbietern und sagen, das sind die, sag ich mal, Features, die wir haben und da brauchen wir eben Standard. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Aushandlungsprozess, ja. Und da darf man sich nichts vormachen. Das wird auch natürlich auch mit Arbeit verbunden sein. Aber ich glaube, also um mal eine historische Anekdote zu bringen, der Erfinder des Protokolls für E-Mail-Anhänge hat mal gesagt, wenn wir heute, in der heutigen Zeit, mit dieser Zentralisierung, die wir haben in allen Bereichen, wenn heute jemand das Protokoll für E-Mail erfinden würde, dann hätten wir einen de facto E-Mail-Anbieter der Welt. Weil niemand würde das als offenen Standard platzieren wollen. Alle würden sagen, ich möchte, dass alle bitte gefälligst zu mir gehen. Da gibt es diese Fahrtabhängigkeiten. Ich glaube, historisch haben wir da den richtigen Zeitpunkt verpasst. Das hätte man viel früher angehen müssen. Trotzdem bin ich überzeugt davon, man darf nicht aufhören, da in die Richtung zu gehen. Wenn man sagt, das ist so ein Riesenproblem mit Facebook, wie das jetzt momentan funktioniert, und das ist eine Machtkonzentration, und dieses Problem wird ja nicht kleiner über die Zeit, sondern eher größer. Was spricht dagegen, dann auch mal unglaublich viel Geld in Forschung für freie Software, freie Standards und so weiter da mal reinzustecken, damit Leute auch damit arbeiten können? Also es gibt ja schon Projekte, die versuchen, dezentrale Netzwerke zu machen. Es gibt auch Projekte wie beispielsweise Friendlycar. Das ist ein alternatives soziales Netzwerk. Da sitzt jemand, der macht sich unglaublich viel Arbeit, immer wieder ein kleines Hintertürchen nach Facebook reinzubekommen, damit man zumindest rein und raus posten kann. Und der kriegt seinen Weg immer wieder verbaut. Und das macht Facebook absichtlich, weil Facebook natürlich überhaupt gar keinen Interesse an Interoperabilität hat. Und deshalb bräuchte es da auch eine gesetzliche Vorgabe, weil freiwillig wären die das nicht machen.
Genau, das ist eine Frage des politischen Willens. Das eine ist vielleicht auch große Anbieter dazu zu verpflichten. Das andere ist selber auch, also der Staat fördert ja Forschung beispielsweise. Die EU hat fette Forschungsprogramme Horizon 2020, wo extrem viel Geld in Technologieforschung geht. Auch die Bundesregierung gibt ja Start-up-Förderung und so weiter. Nur ist das bislang halt überhaupt nicht an Kriterien gebunden. Was wollen wir eigentlich? Was für Innovationen wollen wir? Was für Start-ups oder was für Technologie wollen wir eigentlich entwickeln? An welche Werte soll das gebunden sein? Ich glaube, da gäbe es schon Mittel und Wege, das viel stärker voranzutreiben, wenn dann der politische Wille da wäre.
Das Grundproblem, was man hier hat, ist, dass man halt, egal wie man es dreht und wenn, selbst wenn man jetzt sagt, man macht ein staatliches oder ein öffentlich-rechtliches oder ein Vereinsnetzwerk, durch diesen Netzwerkeffekt läuft es, gibt es immer eine Eigendynamik oder einen Anreiz, dass es immer wieder an den Punkt kommt, wo ein einzelner Anbieter einfach auf, sage ich mal, den Markt kontrolliert oder die meisten Nutzer hat. Und wo diese Machtasymetrie da ist, dann verfühlt es natürlich total dazu, das auszunutzen, ob es jetzt aus kommerziellen oder politischen Gründen ist. Und ja, dieses Problem, der also die Zentralität an sich oder diese Machtasymetrie ist, ja, das grundlegende Problem.
Das hört sich trotzdem so ein bisschen frustrierend an, weil die Frage ist natürlich, wie ist das umsetzbar? Gibt es irgendwas, die Positivbeispiele?
Ja, also es ist eigentlich gar nicht frustrierend, weil man sieht ja, dass es alternative soziale Netzwerke gibt. Es gibt auch eine sehr aktive Entwickler-Community, die sich damit beschäftigt. Und es gibt da auch immer wieder, sag ich mal, Neuentwicklungen oder neue Versuche und Lernerfolge. Und ich finde, das ist total super zu sehen, dass es eben, obwohl der Staat bis jetzt da unglaublich gepennt hat, in ordentlicher Weise Förderung rauszugeben, trotzdem Leute sagen, ja, ich denke, das ist der richtige Weg und diesen richtigen Weg müssen wir gehen. Und vielleicht braucht es auch alles auf einmal. Vielleicht, sag ich mal, in die richtige Richtung forschen, gleichzeitig gucken, ob man gemeinsame Standards macht und gleichzeitig noch die Datenschutzverstöße richtig teuer zu machen. Und gleichzeitig zu sagen, na ja, wir müssen Unternehmen einfach grundsätzlich verbieten, bestimmte Daten überhaupt zu verwerten.
Und bei Messengern gibt es, finde ich, positive Beispiele. Also Messenger ist ja so ein anderes Ding. Da gibt es ja inzwischen gute Alternativen zu WhatsApp. Es gäbe keinen Grund mehr, bei WhatsApp zu hängen eigentlich. Auch da wieder die Frage nach der Netzwerkeffekt. Auch da wieder die Frage nach der Interoperabilität. Es gibt sehr gute Alternativen.
Naja, aber da ist tatsächlich der Punkt, da müssen wir auch noch mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Aber es gibt ja keinen, also meiner Meinung nach oder meinem Empfinden nach, keinen einzigen Messenger, der perfekt ist.
Ja, aber das gilt vor allem für Dienste und Produkte.
Das gilt, naja, aber die Frage zu sagen, du hast halt dieses eine Medium, wo alle sind und dann sagst du ja komm mal darüber. Ich hab das einmal gemacht mit einem Messenger und ich kann das jetzt in meiner Filterbabel vielleicht noch ein, also Lifetime gesprochen, in meiner Lebenszeit kann ich noch einmal meiner Family sagen, wechselt bitte den Messenger. Es gibt momentan keinen, den ich empfehlen würde.
Was stört dich an Signal?
An Signal stört mich, dass das verpflichtend das Telefonbuch hochlädt. Du findest immer eine Sache, die sozusagen, die nicht ein kleines Ding ist, sondern die wirklich relevant, störend ist. Und deswegen, weiß ich nicht so genau, eine Frage, die wir auch noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, ist ja tatsächlich zu sagen, also dieses Ding, ich nehme Leute mit, ob das nicht schon fast eine Spur zu weit ist, weil davor das Problem ist ja, dass man überhaupt ein Bewusstsein dafür entwickelt, dass man auch so, dass man gar nicht auftauchen will. Ich kenne dieses Problem, ich mache ein Foto und ich stelle das natürlich online. Kennt ihr das auch?
Ja, also es ist natürlich immer so eine soziale Drucksituation. Also wenn, also ich sage immer ganz bewusst, hey Leute, grundsätzlich, wenn ihr Fotos macht, bitte fragt mich vorher. Also ja, das ist in manchen Kontexten auch schon keine Selbstverständlichkeit. Und wenn ihr das auf Facebook stellen wollt, dann sagt mir bitte Bescheid, weil dann gehe ich aus dem Bild. Und das mache ich nicht, weil ich euch nicht mag. Ganz im Gegenteil. Die Sachen, die mir ganz besonders viel bedeuten, die möchte ich nicht auf Facebook posten. Und wenn man das den Leuten so erklärt, dann verstehen sie es auch. Aber trotzdem gibt es eben diese sozialen Drucksituationen. Als ich studiert hab, wollte mein Jahrgang, die Altklausuren auf Facebook in der Gruppe tauschen. Und ja, da war ich, die nicht auf Facebook war damals, und ein Freund von mir, und wir haben zusammen dann dafür lobbyiert, bitte ein alternatives Netzwerk zu nutzen, was ich dann aufgesetzt hab. Und das hat auch funktioniert. Also meine Erfahrung ist, es macht Sinn im Familien- und Freundeskreis, einfach mal drüber zu sprechen, ist vielleicht auch ein anderes, also ein ganz angenehmes Thema für den Rostertisch im Vergleich zu anderen Themen. Und ja, also ich glaube, Menschen denken auch zunehmend differenzierter darüber. Je länger man das auch selbst nutzt, je mehr Datenskandale.
Also warte mal, heißt das sozusagen, also man ist halt jemand, der sich schon seit Jahrzehnten gefühlt mit dem Thema Beschäftigte oder Umständen viel frustrierter. Also sozusagen, man bricht jetzt ab, hat keinen Bock mehr. Aber dabei ist jetzt vielleicht doch die Zeit gekommen, wo alle anfangen, drüber nachzudenken.
Ja klar.
Ich glaube schon, dass das gesellschaftliche Bewusstsein für das Thema auf jeden Fall wächst. Mit jedem Skandal sozusagen wird es deutlicher. Das ist ja auch das, dass ich, wenn ich hier so einen blöden Persönlichkeitstest mit einer Facebook-App mache, dass das dann die Daten von mir und von meinen Freunden sammelt und ich auf dieser Grundlage dann später politische Botschaften zugeschnitten bekomme. Diesen gedanklichen Schritt, den muss man ja erstmal nachvollziehen können. Und ich glaube, da kommen wir als Gesellschaft hin. Für mich ist dann aber wieder die Frage, ich finde es okay, das auf einer individuellen Ebene irgendwie zu diskutieren, Freunde zu überzeugen usw. Ich glaube aber, es ist einfach ein gesellschaftliches Problem, für das wir politische Lösungen brauchen. Und ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen, es fehlt da einfach bislang am politischen Willen, das auch anders zu gestalten. Ich finde es gerade beim Thema Datenschutz, auf EU-Ebene wird gerade die E-Privacy-Verordnung verhandelt, wo es darum ginge, Nutzerinnen und Nutzern zu erleichtern, sich gegen Third-Party-Tracking zu wehren. Dass der Do-Not-Track-Standard oder etwas Ähnliches beispielsweise verpflichtend wäre. Eine unfassbare Lobby-Kampagne, die sich dagegen wehrt und die eben ziemlich erfolgreich ist dabei, die Politik davon zu überzeugen, dass es eine schlechte Idee ist, dass es das Internet letztendlich kaputt macht, wenn Nutzerinnen und Nutzer selbst darüber entscheiden können, ob sie durch ihre Bewegung durchs Web verfolgt werden wollen oder nicht und ob auf dieser Grundlage in Werbung zugespielt werden soll. Also ePrivacy-Verordnung an der Stelle kann ich nicht oft genug sagen, ist der Datenschutz-Battle, der gerade stattfindet, leider ziemlich unterm Radar, wo es im EU-Parlament eine echt gute Positionierung gab, wo trotz eines harten Widerstands der Konservativen es gelungen ist, an der Stelle eine starke...
Jetzt muss ich aber leider sagen, du sagst so ganz am Ende der Sendung, wo wir keine Zeit mehr haben, ein neues Fass aufgemacht, was wir nicht mal noch genauer erläutert kriegen. Möglicherweise wird das dann ein Thema einer der kommenden Sendungen. Eine Datenschutzgrundverordnung ist jetzt gerade und dann später kommt die E-Barris-Richtlinie. Aber wir können mal festhalten, auf der persönlichen Ebene nochmal, liebe Nerds, gebt nicht auf. Liebe Nicht-Nerds, wenn euch die Nerds erklären, warum gewisse Dinge vielleicht noch bedenkenswert sind, wollen sie euch nicht den Spaß verderben, sondern haben Interesse daran, dass das Leben möglichst gut bleibt. Das haben wir in den letzten zwei Stunden auch versucht. Hoffen, dass es gelungen ist und freuen uns über Kommentare unter chaosradio.ccc.de Vielen Dank Katascha und Ingo, dass ihr hier wart. Wo kann man euch das nächste Mal sehen, lesen, hören, was auch immer?
Ja, also am 27. April, da erscheint so ein Buch von mir. Ich unter anderem mein Facebook Trauma verarbeite, aber auch diverse Traumata mit Polizeidatenbanken. Und mein Daten und ja, es heißt die Daten, die ich rief. Und ihr könnt das, wenn euch interessiert, gerne lesen.
Mich kann man regelmäßig auf netzpolitik.org lesen. Unter anderem viel zu Facebook, WhatsApp, Cambridge Analytica in der letzten Zeit, aber auch zu anderen Themen, wo es um Digital Rights sozusagen geht, das größere Feld, vor allen Dingen im Bereich Daten und das nächste Mal erleben am kommenden Dienstag in der Seabase hier in Berlin beim Netzpolitischen Abend der digitalen Gesellschaft, Thema Dateneigentum und Datenökonomie, ein Themenabend der digitalen Gesellschaft zu diesem Thema. Ich kann nur empfehlen, da vorbeizukommen.
Dann vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart, dass ihr mit uns alles geteilt und so geduldig erklärt habt. Vor allem sehr gerne. Und im Hintergrund, man kann das ja auch sehen, zum Beispiel dieses Chaosradio, haben Mo und Dani Mo heute dafür gesorgt, dass die Technik überall stattfindet und haben außerdem noch ein paar Veranstaltungstipps für euch. Ja, zum einen die Mesh-Syndere. Das ist also eine Veranstaltung zu Wi-Fi und Mesh-Netzwerken. Mesh-Netzwerke, das sind die Dinger, wo man drahtlos versucht, Strecken zu überwinden. Mit Vortragsprogramm und Workshop vom 7. bis zum 13. Mai. Mehr gibt es auf www.wirelessmeshup.org. Und ganz aktuell das Easter Hack, das geht morgen los. Und ist ein sehr schönes CCC-Treffen, nicht ganz so groß wie der Kongress, aber auch Vortragsprogramme. Und die könnt ihr euch live auch angucken unter eh18.easterhackhegg.eu. Auf jeden Fall. Gut, dann vielen Dank. Dann bleibt mir nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich wünsche euch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network, Biat.